nous sommes en direct de la passe avec
holly vargas reporter de caoutchouc news
c'est notre rubrique
vu de l'extérieur ce soir bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous au libéria sans direct
de la passe le procureur donc général
bolivien accusé l'ancien président
morales de délits présumés de terrorisme
et de leur financement est à nouveau
demandé son arrestation de quoi
s'agit-il précisément et pourquoi autant
de détermination de la part du procureur
n'a de l'aude et la détention préventive
d'evo morales
suite à des accusations de terrorisme
qui sont liés à la résistance
démocratique qui a après le renversement
de hot shots 2019
beaucoup de personnes dans le pays
pensent qu'il s'agit d'une tentative
d'empêcher le mouvement vers le
socialisme mas d'evo morales de
concourir lors des élections à venir et
il y à un autre maître affaire dans le
même temps c'est le cas autour de la
fraude électorale présumée 7 octobre
2019 des études internationales en
pleuvait qu'il n'y avait pas eu de
fraude lors de ces élections remportées
par evo morales c'est un rapport par
exemple repris par le new york times et
le washington post
il a montré qu'il y avait des erreurs
dans les hypothèses selon lequel il y
aurait eu fraude électorale et pour
cette affaire servira également à
essayer de bannir à la participation du
mas dans les élections de septembre
le gouvernement a tout intérêt à bannir
ce mouvement car un sondage publié
aujourd'hui montre que le parti d'evo
morales
à quinze points d'avancé dans les
sondages par rapport aux à la seconde
place et pourrait bien remporter les
élections
le nouveau gouvernement est donc très
inquiet et redoutent que leurs projets
liés au libéral visant à orienter le
pays vers les états unis s'effondrerait
le 6 septembre
quelles sont les chances cette fois ci
que ces poursuites aboutisse parce qu on
se souvient que la première fois c'est
interpol qui n'avait pas donné suite un
puisque evo morales n'est pas en bolivie
x est la justice internationale à police
internationale en tout cas de prendre le
relais quelles chances de réussite pour
le procureur le système judiciaire
libyen est sous le contrôle du nouveau
gouvernement
on s'attend donc à ce que le jugement se
fasse contre evo morales contre le mas
au niveau international c'est une autre
question
effectivement interpol a déjà rejeté la
première tentative en janvier d'arrêter
evo morales nous avons également vu en
equator que le gouvernement a essayé à
trois reprises de faire de mettre en
place une alerte rouge pour l'ex
président de gauche
et à chaque fois interpol a rejeté ces
tentatives manquées la colo on ecuador
comme en bolivie
il s'agit en fait d'efforts pour mener
une persécution politique et les avocats
de morlaàs en argentine montre qu'il
s'agit d'une preuve que la bolivie
devenue un état policier
l'état l'a l'état de droit n'a plus lieu
n'a plus cours et nous espérons que les
organisations internationales s'en
rendre compte
nous espérons que le monde se rend
compte qu'on prend que la bolivie
effectivement est devenu autoritariste
où il n'y a plus de
démocratie je pense qu'on va le
comprendre au niveau international alors
effectivement le président morales l'ex
président morales a réagi sur twitter il
affirme que cette accusation est une
preuve supplémentaire de la persécution
politique systématique du gouvernement
et il rajoute la démocratie et l'état de
droit
reviendront bientôt en bolivie ça veut
dire que il estime ses chances grande de
revenir au pays et même aux affaires
est-ce que les boliviens le soutiendrez
selon vous le parti le mas jeu
remportera les élections du 6 septembre
d'après les sondages les intentions de
vote sont à hauteur de 41% et la seconde
place n'attend que 20%
donc c'est le plus grand parti du pays
et si les élections sont libres et
justes alors le mouvement vers le
socialisme le mas les remportera et evo
morales pourra revenir le pays la grande
question c'est est-ce que les élections
pourraient avoir lieu
et si elles ont lieu seront elles
effectivement libres et équitables
les coupes de gens considèrent qu'elles
n'auront pas lieu
du coup le ministre aux places est telle
que le ministre de l'intérieur arturo
mûri lots ont été très clairs sur le
fait qu'il ne pensait pas qu'il devrait
y avoir des élections en septembre
beaucoup de groupes d'extrême droite ont
déclaré être prêts à se mobiliser contre
de telles élections et il se fonde sur
la crise du coronavirus et sur les
risques de transmission comme prétexte
pour interdire ces élections mais avec
les menaces de manifestations de
mobilisation sur en bien compte que ce
n'est pas vraiment un véritable sujet
d'inquiétude ce qui les préoccupe c'est
le risque de voir un retour
de evo morales et beaucoup de personnes
au sein du régime dont le ministre de
l'intérieur a retour au mojito serait
obligé de quitter le pays ou risquer la
prison
si evo morales revenez si merci au lit
vargas d'avoir été avec nous pour notre
rubrique vu de l'extérieur ce soir